this is Puerto Rico on a calm night in
July 2017 here it is again after
Hurricane Maria in September the storms
impact has been catastrophic it was at
its strongest when it was passing over
the most populated parts of the island
which is home to about 3.4 million
people and knocked off Puerto Rico's
power grid and now it'll be months
before most of the island has
electricity again and what's made
recovery particularly hard is that the
government has no money that's partly
because of its complex relationship with
the US mainland Puerto Rico became a
u.s. Commonwealth in 1952 but nearly
half of all Americans don't know that
people born in Puerto Rico are US
citizens the islands economic downturn
can be traced back to the 1960s and 70s
when a special tax break from Congress
led u.s. companies to set up shop in
Puerto Rico then between 1993 and 2006
Congress phased out those tax breaks and
companies left the island in droves
taking thousands of jobs with them
economic growth slowed to a crawl and
hordes of people started leaving the
island the number of Puerto Ricans
living in the US mainland doubled
between 2005 and 2015 and as a tax based
shrink Puerto Rico went into massive
debt to pay its bills today it owes more
than seventy billion dollars mostly to
Wall Street creditors in May of 2017 the
island filed for protection similar to
bankruptcy budgets for hospitals schools
and roads were slashed another US policy
that led to Puerto Rico's economic
turmoil is the Merchant Marine act of
1920 or the Jones Act it places huge
tariffs on any foreign imports although
President Trump suspended the Jones Act
in the wake of Hurricane Maria those
costs have been passed down to Puerto
Ricans for decades since Puerto Rico
imports 84 percent of its food people
they're often paid double what they
would on the mainland for basic
necessities the high cost of living is
one of the reasons 43% of residents live
in poverty crucially the islands
financial woes have kept it from
investing in the kind of modern
automated power plant technology that's
characteristic of the mainland US
and that's gonna make recovery difficult
most power plants on the mainland rely
on natural gas with some coal nuclear
and renewables but Puerto Rico's
old-fashioned plant still generate
two-thirds of their power from burning
oil and all that oil has to be imported
in the aftermath of Hurricane Maria the
power plants are mostly intact but
nearly 80% of the transmission lines
that carry power are down and so are the
roads that bring oil to the power plants
while the islands power plants are on
the southern coast most people live in
the north and between those two sit
dense forests and mountains apart from
the challenging terrain Puerto Rico's
electric utility company prepa relies
heavily on workers with extensive
knowledge and those workers have been
leaving since 2012 30 percent of
proposed employees have retired or left
for the mainland in search of better
jobs electrical engineers from Puerto
Rico can make about 27 percent more
money on the US mainland according to
its director prep azan the verge of
collapse because there's no personnel to
operate it and that was before the storm
without technicians to repair all of
these broken transmission lines Puerto
Ricans are expected to be without power
for months and the consequences could be
dire without electricity to pump water
into homes it's difficult to find clean
water for drinking and bathing no air
conditioning our fans can mean increased
risk of heatstroke and without
refrigeration to keep insulin and other
drugs from expiring people are at risk
of death all of this means that millions
of US citizens for the foreseeable
future will be living in conditions that
we usually associate with places very
far away
[Music]
you